Thoughts on how to deal with toxic slash negative people.
Oh,
those people.
Yeah.
So first of all,
it's important to recognize that those people exist everywhere and everybody's
got to deal with me.
If you run into one of these people,
don't get all surprised as if they're a lone ranger out there being negative.
No,
there's negative rangers all over the place.
So we gotta do you gotta know how to deal with them?
And it's so,
so when you're dealing with someone like that,
first of all,
confronting them,
of course,
as you can probably predict,
is not usually the best option because all you're doing is you're,
you're attack and they're heavily defended position,
which,
which is not good.
So one of the techniques that I use when dealing with these kind of people is I
absorb,
I absorb their critiques,
I absorb their toxicity,
I absorb their negativity.
Now obviously this takes a little bit of strength,
right?
You can't be taking stuff personally.
You have to,
in order to learn how to absorb them,
you gotta say,
okay,
I'm just going doing this for the team.
Right?
But it looks like,
for instance,
when they say,
oh,
this is horrible.
I don't say no.
It's not horrible.
I don't just go right back at him.
I say,
yeah,
you know what?
We definitely got some room for improvement,
right?
So I kind of just deflect it.
Kind of just absorb it.
Right?
It was the orbit a little bit.
Because what they want to do is they're lashing out,
right?
They're throwing the negativity.
They liked those explosions.
They like to see it hit something and blow up.
They,
that's what they're doing.
That's how they roll.
So you're going to absorb,
you gonna catch it and pull it in.
Right?
So when they're like,
we can never do this.
I don't say we can absolutely do this.
No,
because you didn't.
You're just go,
you're going to create the explosion that they're looking for in San Jose.
You know what?
We might not be able to do it.
I'm going to give it a,
I'm going to give it a good solid try.
I'm gonna try and make it happen.
Right?
So we're just deflected that a little bit into going to show you some other
negative thing.
And you know,
if they say,
oh,
this is stupid,
I don't say no,
this is the most brilliant thing I've ever seen.
I don't do that.
No.
Go head to head.
I'm going to say,
you know what,
there's definitely some room for improvement the next time around.
You're right,
100% oh yeah,
you just got deflected.
And those reactions,
they disarm these ultra negative people and
it kind of takes their,
their fight from the minute also makes them look like emotional extremist.
So with the group,
right,
when somebody calls that out in the group and they're common across all extreme
and you just absorb it and negate it a little bit,
it negates their view or I shouldn't say negate,
negate.
And it's like totally Latins and cross out when you just absorb it and deflected
a little bit,
the rest of the team goes on.
Yet,
you know,
oh echo,
he's just super emotional.
He's in negative.
They see him for what he is,
which help is helpful for you.
Right.
And then once I'm done absorbing their attacks and taken some of those shots,
no big deal,
then I'm going to start to override them somewhat with some with some positivity
which is going to be directed at them.
Right.
So they were all negative,
but I'm going to say,
Hey,
what you did there really work well or you know what?
good job on that.
I didn't know I did care.
I'd never could have figured that out like you did.
Right.
So I'm going to start,
start getting in their head a little bit and start filling their head with some
positive stuff.
That's right.
That's what I'm going to do.
Bad.
You figured that out better than anybody.
Nicely done.
And I'm bringing them
from the dark side over to the light.
That's what I'm doing.
I'm bringing them over and actually I used to have the funniest up one of my
favorite guys in the seal teams.
He was my,
he was my first deployment to Iraq.
He was the senior enlisted guy in our tasking.
It's an,
and actually we're just bros,
but when one of us would start getting a little off the reservation on something
like getting all addicted to some id or something,
the other one we were doing,
we would be looking like I be telling them,
look,
we need to do this and this is bullshit.
We need to do.
And he looked at me like he'd be like,
come back,
come back to the life.
We're over here.
It's okay.
We're all going to be okay.
So when I would start getting negative,
he would start pulling me back to the light.
Right.
And same thing with,
with me,
with him,
he would get,
he would get all,
you know,
get all,
matter of fact he's the guy.
Um,
I remember when we talked about,
well if fire repeat then yeah,
no,
simplify,
amplify and repeat.
That's a,
yeah,
that's it.
He would also have to bring me back from the dark side and I have to do it to
him too,
if he started getting a little too negative.
Um,
good times.
But the,
the last thing I want to do with someone that's being super negative is I am
actually want to,
I want to give them some ownership.
I want to give them some ownership,
some ability to make changes,
some ability to have some kind of a positive impact on the mission.
So I'm going to pick something that I think they can step up and handle,
right?
Something that is within their grasp and realm and ability and I'm going to give
it to him and then I'm going to give them,
I'm going to give him to kind of overload them with help and with assistance and
with guidance to make sure that they win
and that's going to start spinning them in a more positive direction.
Yeah.
So that's my way to deal with the big negative people out there.
Just absorb and slowly counter.
I like to know your are,
you'd be like,
Hey,
like oh you figured that out.
And I said this before,
but a good one is to be light,
to say,
hey,
that's what I like about you.
You're real,
whatever,
x,
Y,
z.
You know,
you're getting that feeling like,
because people said that to me.
That's what I like about you.
You're real whatever,
you know,
and it makes you want to like continue to be that they know and you,
you're like,
Hey,
he thinks I'm,
you know,
a problem solver.
Some of I'm going to be aware and just continue to solve problems.
You know,
you put the self fulfilling prophecy in their own heads and positive things that
you want them to do.
Exactly.